>> Brian: IT'S LIKE SOMEONE
BROKE INTO THE STUDIO.
BILL de BLASIO IS FIVE DAYS INTO
HIS PIPE DREAM OF PRESIDENT.
NOW THE QUESTION IS WHO WILL BE
NEW YORK CITY'S MAYOR.
SOME SAY OCASIO-CORTEZ WILL BE
THE TOP CANDIDATE.
ONE COULD IMAGINE THAT THE
PROSPECT OF MAYORAL RACE WOULD
LOOK ATTRACTIVE FOR THE YOUNG
SOCIALITE.
>> Dana: THIS SHOWS A LACK OF
IMAGINATION, TOTAL LAZINESS OR
THEY REALLY DON'T WANT HER TO BE
IN CONGRESS.
GET HER OFF THE STAGE.
SHE'S NOW THE -- BESIDES
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE MOST
POPULAR TO THE BIDEN TEAM.
THE MAYOR'S OFFICE, YOU HAVE TO
HAVE EXECUTIVE DECISION
EXPERIENCE.
SHE'S BEEN IN CONGRESS SIX
MONTHS.
SO LIKE PER EXECUTIVE DECISION
MAKING MAKE BILL de BLASIO LOOK
LIKE MIKE BLOOMBERG.
SHE SHOULD STAY WHERE SHE IS.
SHE COULD BE A KING MAKER.
>> Brian: I FIND HER DECISIVE,
CONFIDENT, CHARISMATIC AND HARD
WORKING.
JESSE, CAN YOU FAULT ME ON ANY
OF THOSE FOUR QUALITIES?
>> Jesse: YOU WANT HER TO RUN
FOR MAYOR SO YOU CAN FOLLOW HER
EVERY DAY.
>> Dana: YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> Jesse: SHE'S GOT EVERYTHING
YOU SAID.
SHE DOES NOT HAVE THE TECHNICAL
ACUMEN, THE MANAGERIAL
EXPERIENCE TO RUN THE CITY.
THE CITY NEEDS TO BE RUN.
YOU CAN'T TWEET ABOUT THE PRICE
OF CROISSANTS.
SHE WOULD RUN THE CITY IN THE
GROUND SO FAST, YOU WOULD GET A
REPUBLICAN AFTER THE FIRST TERM.
>> Brian: WE'RE ON AUTOMATIC
PILOT RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE A MAYOR --
>> Jesse: THE SHOW OR --
>> Emily: I HAVE TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR AFTER I -- WERE WE LIVE?
AT 10:00 HE WORKS OUT.
AT 12:00, HE GETS TO THE OFFICE.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
POST," LAYS DOWN IN HIS OFFICE
WITH THE DOOR OPEN WITH THE
NEWSPAPER ON HIS HEAD AND THE
CITY IS STILL RUN SOMETHIN
CITY IS STILL RUNNIOMETHIN
CITY IS STILL RUNNING.
AOC.
HE SHOULD BE GREAT.
>> Emily: HE'S ROCK BOTTOM.
THAT'S WHY HE HAS A 18% APPROVAL
RATE.
THERE'S NO REASON THAT SHE CAN'T
DO LIKE GIVEN THE ENERGY BILL
THE MAJOR JUST PASSED.
IT'S WISHFUL THINKING TO REMOVE
HER FROM THE NATIONAL STAGE.
SHE'S DRIVING POLICY AND
CONVERSATION.
YOU KNOW LOOKING GOOD AMERICA IS
IN THE CHLOE KARDSHIAN LINE IS.
>> Jesse: I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
>> Dana: I'M LISTENING.
>> Emily: IT WAS LIKE JUST LIKE
HOOPS AND RED LIPSTICK GO
TOGETHER ON AOC, SO TOO DOES OUR
LOOKS.
SO ALL FACETS OF NORMAL LIFE
OUTSIDE THE POLITICAL SPHERE,
PEOPLE ARE REFERENCING HER.
IT NEEDS TO BE HARNESSED SOME
WAY, THE DEMOCRATS, BUT THEY
WANT TO COON TAKEN HER.
THEY'LL PROBABLY SAY SHE'LL BE
FATIGUED IF THE REPUBLICANS TAKE
BACK OVER THE HOUSE IN 2020 IS
LAME.
>> Jesse: WOULD YOUR WEAR THOSE
JEANS?
>> Juan: IF I COULD FIT IN THEM.
GEE, MOM JEANS FOR ME.
I MUST SAY, DANA IS ON POINT.
THE REST OF YOU MISSED IT HERE.
>> Emily: I AGREED WITH HER.
>> Juan: LET ME TELL YOU, DANA
IS ON POINT, THIS IS A
CONVERSATION AMONG REPUBLICANS
IN THE SUN.
PEOPLE AT A DINNER PARTY, UPPER
EAST SIDE TYPES HAVING A
CONVERSATION.
THIS IS NOT THE SAME ELECTORATE.
THE SECOND THING IS, GUESS WHAT?
THEY ARE THINKING OH, de BLASIO
HIT ROCK BOTTOM.
THEN YOU SAY SHE WILL TAKE US
FURTHER DOWN.
THAT'S CRAZINESS.
>> Emily: SHE BLEW THE AMAZON
DEAL.
>> Dana: I BET HE SHOULD BE
BETTER.
>> Juan: I THINK MIKE BLOOMBERG
THOUGHT THIS WAS GREAT TRAINING.
RUDY GULIANI THOUGHT IT WAS
GREAT TRAINING.
DEALING WITH NATIONAL SECURITY A
BIG SCHOOL SYSTEM A LARGE POLICE
FORCE.
ALL THE ISSUES ARE THERE.
THE QUESTION IS, DOES ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ GET KICKED OUT, DO
REPUBLICANS REGAIN THE HOUSE
NEXT TIME AROUND?
DOES SHE DECIDE OH, MAYBE I
SHOULD CHALLENGE CHARLES SCHUMER
IN NEW YORK FOR THE SENATE SEAT.
>> Jesse: I KNOW AMERICA'S MAYOR
AND AOC IS NO AMERICA'S MAYOR.
>> Juan: THANK GOD.
>> Brian: RUDY PAVED THE ROADS.
WE STOPPED PICK POCKETERS.
>> Juan: I'M GOING TO USE ONE OF
JESSE'S LINE.
HE OPENED THE DOOR FOR
de BLASIO, HIS POLICIES.
>> Jesse: HE FOLLOWED BLOOMBERG.
>> Juan: I'M SAYING THOSE KIND
OF HARSH POLICIES GULIANI TIME
IN THE LIGHT, IT CHANGED THE
ATTITUDE.